i think it's a tragedy when you're
trying to do a performance art and
pretend you're somebody that you're not
trying to make things that you don't
like i think that's the real tragedy i
think that's a real waste of time
we hear a lot about the 99 of
screenplays written today are quote
unquote horrible
what's been your experience with
screenplays that you've read yeah i
don't think that like
that many are like just
total trash
i think that like
for me when i look at it as somebody
to either like represent a writer or the
producer project
that it
it's not like something is
the it's
complete completely
not
on the level
it's more
does it align with my taste so
i'm not
being shocked by the
bad scripts i'm reading and maybe i'm
not being exposed to really bad ones but
for whatever ends up on my to-do list to
read
it typically is actually pretty good
there's never been anything where
you were surprised that someone would
submit something that wasn't finished
well i tend to not just
take on
submissions
that the email
doesn't prick my interest
i mean i have to see a log line
of something
that makes me want to read it
and it's
presented professionally in the email or
i get a script from
a trusted contact
or
like a cover fly or find something on
blacklist and it's got good feedback on
it
it's probably pretty good like it's not
there isn't a
incredible deviation
from
what i'll imagine it to be
to what it is and
how horrible it is
what i rarely find is
writing that
gets me in the in the mindset of
oh my god this is something that i have
to get involved with
that's the the difference it's not about
wow it's all it's all bad it's more of
like what's going to make me care more
because i do have to look at all my
other responsibilities
what what's going to make me want to
like open up space
in my mental bandwidth and on my
schedule to really
get behind
a project
that's what we're talking about but it's
not like
i'm seeing so many
bad
writers
and maybe through my filter systems
because i'm engaged with a network maybe
i'm just not seeing those
what do you think 99 of screenplays get
wrong
i don't know
what they get wrong
because
i don't know the ratio of scripts that i
like and then at a certain point
it's also a tasting because they're
perfectly talented writers that will
find managers
that have different tastes than mine or
i might find a writer that some other
manager doesn't like so
i can't say in like a
as a number
in a sense that this percentage won't
won't get it i could just say that it's
just my sensibilities and
those things
those those things are just like
subjective and
they guide my curation
so
i can't tell writers to write exactly in
the way that i
connect with because that's their voice
and that's how they want to write so if
there's something that
i fall in love with that's great but
just the stars aligning so it's more of
an organic
type of thing that i have as a manager
where i'm like
wow this is really
special
and
this is what i want to watch
on tv
or i want to see in the theater
and that's
more of that subjective taste
than it is that there's just all these
bad writers making mistakes
it's it's in the same way like i at home
i have unlimited options uh to stream
practically
what am i choosing to watch like that's
more of a reflective of the sense of are
these do i connect with these writers or
not is what would i actually sit back
and watch
what am i gonna
what am i gonna enjoy on the weekend so
but i don't wanna like
speak to all these writers and say look
you're all messing up as much as i have
certain taste
that defines
my uh my business
can you explain meta to me
the the sense that there is a
like if you think about i don't know uh
deadpool there is a
a commentary on the superhero
genre within
his you know his his performances
his jokes the the character is
constantly commenting on
the
the type of
world that he occupies
or if you look at like scream the
characters in some ways are commenting
on the slasher genre
so i mean that's my
i guess
you know take on what medic could be i'm
sure there's ways to deconstruct that or
explore that concept but that's what
initially comes to mind
do you think that's more prevalent now
i do think that was definitely a
movement in the horror genre
and the
with scream i think scream was
definitely
an approach but it's a device so i mean
i'm sure it's used across genres
currently
but it's hard to like say
if it's an exact
wave that is starting to become dominant
or it's picking up or it's just
part of
the you know the culture and we're just
kind of experiencing it off and on but
it's not like
there's all these meta
creators that are just driving you know
this movement i don't know
how does a writer know they're too late
to a genre like they're catching it when
it's on its way down and it's been done
too much and they think that it's a wave
they want to ride but the waves are
already about to crash
i think that like there's a pastiche
that sometimes is popular and
it's hard to really like
have a handle on it exactly but you just
feel it it's not an intellectual thing
you feel certain things like
an ebb and flow of an approach
you know
but i don't think anything
ever dies
i think it's just
find another way
into
into the minds of of creators and
audiences and maybe
it's not the trending idea
but it still exists i mean if you think
about fashion
you'll see fashion resurface all the
time
i mean everything's 90s now so you know
yeah stonewash it's all about that you
know it's a good thing we saved the
jackets yeah exactly so
you know 90s never died it's just
there's just a
there's always been ebbs and flows of
ideas and identities and
and types of characters and stories we
see but i don't think that anyone's too
late to party i think the problem
sometimes is
that
the the the messaging to some script
writers
is
it's done almost like it's like a tech
startup where it's just like here's the
space we gotta occupy it oh no this is
crowded or you know and it's
this very business and very pragmatic
mindset that you apply to potentially
another field
but i think that like as a writer
you should write what you love
and
how much you align it with like being
pragmatic that's up to you or your reps
but i i do think getting too caught up
in the the stock market or the trending
of what entrepreneurs are selling this
it starts changing
the mindset of
the creative process
and it's very hard to write a script
so if you're looking at like deadline
hollywood or variety or any of those
things and they're like i gotta write
this or write that
i think that starts to become you're
becoming more reactive
and i think that
to really develop your voice and really
build out your your portfolio it's
almost like you got to exert yourself
onto the world and take up space and
kind of push your ideas forward
versus just you know counter punching
uh
because you're just dealing with things
coming at you and i think with that
mentality
you know maybe you do make some money
but you may not feel like you really own
it and you might not feel like it's
yours and i think it's way better
to stick to what you're actually
care about like if you really love
campy
you know
rom-coms or whatever it is and you know
all about them you should write to that
you should write to what you love
because then you know it on a more
specific level you should write what you
care about or else it's just like a
weird you know weird game and then it's
more than you're playing the business of
it
but
that's not going to inspire people
because you're not doing something that
you're feeling you're doing something
that you're thinking you're thinking
that is everybody loves x or
but i think you need to be able to be
comfortable with a risk when you become
a writer
then when you write a script you might
not sell it and that's fine and there's
no there's no shame in writing things
that don't sell they might become a
sample but you don't want to be
constantly
being informed by trends or thought
leaders and all that you just want to
write
about
things that
you that are on your mind that you can't
get out of your mind you know and there
might be a movie that you saw
when you're younger
and that that movie
is a movie that like
inspired you to get into a game and you
want to write to that but it's passe
you should still write to it because
that's what's getting it right it's your
every time you're in the game
and you're creating something
you're learning
it's kind of like if you think about it
like if you're a martial artist
you're not precious when you
work on your
your discipline you're just constantly
perfecting it perfecting it or if you're
a chef you're perfecting your cooking
and it's not like this is the best
cheesecake ever that i'll end all
cheesecakes
and i can never do another one and
that is it no you're just doing it and
keep doing it and learning learning and
learning
and at a certain point
it may not be the projects that you
think are going to be the ones that sell
maybe it's further out that you've
worked worked work work worked and
instantly locks in
because you're not trying to protect
your time so much you're you're more
learning because you're making yourself
better and as you get better and better
you're better for yourself just to
generate a loan and you're also a better
collaborator because you could
articulate your thesis for
for what you're working on and then they
connect with that who you're working
with and just build it out
so i think that it's not about
protecting your
your your time by
choosing
some
get rich quick scheme over
talking about
themes talking about trauma that you've
experienced or
commenting on
the types of
you know tv shows you grow up on
those things
should just drive you and should be your
compass that should always get you back
to what makes you excited and just keep
going back there and go back there and
not look at it as like a cause and
effect like i do this i get that
you know because that's the problem
is that
there's all these ideas of schemes and
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna
make it work there's so many professions
that take a lifetime to learn and
and they are accepted you know to be a
lawyer you don't just become a lawyer
you don't get like a certificate in the
mail and so you're just a lawyer after
like a a week of studying law it's these
things take time so i think the key is
taking the pressure off your shoulders
and just accepting yourself accepting
what you love and accepting what makes
you different
and just making anything even if it's
just an iphone video or something you're
shooting on like on tick tock it doesn't
matter or you're writing tweets or you
write short stories it's just getting
immersed in
what you love
and learning and trying to find friends
that share the same
you know sensibilities
and rinse and repeat
and not thinking
like i need a manager or i need an agent
or i need this no you just need the
platform that allows you to
learn and sharpen
your
your perspective
and if you do these things you become
more valuable because then you become a
specialist you gotta be
okay with the most competitive
quality of any storyteller
is
you got to be more me than anybody else
so that's what i'm saying it's not to
say i want to be the best writer or i
want to be the best director i know i
want to be more me
and i want to
feed
those needs that i have
to obsess over
the directors that i fell in love with
the whatever is a comic creator or the
musicians and if you live in that space
you start picking up
valuable skills you start refining that
way to speak now when they say voice
it's like a signature what is your voice
but they also say voice
because you listen to my voice you can
hear what i'm trying to say you're
connecting with you're communicating
and it takes time
but then you communicate and it connects
if you see like your favorite tv shows
and movies and everything
you're not looking
at the low light reel of the creators
you're looking at the headlines
do you know there's a low light reel to
almost anybody we don't always look cool
the richest people always look cool the
most successful artists always look cool
you're not seeing them
around
making stuff that nobody cares about
we only see when it's just everything
just kind of clicks and then suddenly
they're like
amazing and that's a problem with like
the 30 under 30 or this and that is
obsession with time
we got to get here before this happens
or we got to sell this project because
time's running out
we have time until you're dead you have
time so you should focus on
becoming the most you version
as a creator and then if time goes by
and somehow that manifests
into making all this money and being you
know looking awesome that's fine or you
don't become successful you just
became obsessed with what you love and i
don't think that's a tragedy either
i think it's a tragedy when you're
trying to do a performance art and
pretend you're somebody that you're not
trying to make things that you don't
like i think that's the real tragedy i
think that's a real waste of time
you